i don't know man
but i do i love my family man i come
from a great family man they're
wonderful people
um
i just have you ever been on one of
those family vacations that sounded
really good until you got on the
vacation
and it's a [ __ ] show
has anybody been on a cruise has anybody
ever been on a cruise
royal caribbean go [ __ ] yourself
i got dudes
have you seen the commercials
holy crap hot girls in bikinis diving in
the pools
well-behaved kids playing on deck
happy good-looking people interacting
with each other
none of those people are on my boat
there were 5 000 people with 75 percent
body fat
strapped in teva sandals look like
they're bacon bread right there on their
feet
with little corn chips dangling off the
end
feel my pain feel it
and they're just [ __ ] sweating across
the deck every day
you know where they're going the goddamn
buffet
that's all anybody does is eat on these
boats 24 7 man
i walked into the gym
ghost town
there's dust on the treadmills
but every fat ass in america rented a
scooter riding around the top of that
ship looks like nascar on a saturday
eight days
eight [ __ ] days
oh
and there was this one guy man i swear
to god i love this guy man his name was
bubba bubba [ __ ] you not bubba from
arkansas
bubba was about five six three eighty
wore cargo shorts stuffed with reese's
in case of an emergency
brother and i would wake up in the
morning to watch him eat at the buffet
he would stack a plate like an art form
he would have scrambled eggs as a
foundation
then he put egg rolls his little columns
all around it
put pizza on top of that like ice cream
and everything and then he put a diet
coke under his arm
bubby you got 82 000 calories there
drink the [ __ ] coke man
if people always tell you don't don't
worry about the room don't spend your
money on the room
[ __ ] you
spend every nickel you ever earn spend
your kids college fund on that [ __ ]
room
get something with a window or a balcony
i was in one of those holding cells on
the inside of the boat
four by six room two cots
orange jumpsuit hanging in the closet
and there was a drain in the middle of
the room
hand to god i thought that's where you
peed the first three days i was there
did he find the bathroom this [ __ ]
closet tucked behind the door i'm [ __ ]
like this for five days
oh my god and you start to hate people
you hate people
you see the same faces every day
you're like if i see you walk by my door
one more time i'll stab you in the
[ __ ] neck i swear to god i will
i'll burn those lord of the flies kids
you drag around this boat
why they have shore excursions if you
don't know what shore excursions are
they're time-outs so we all don't shiv
each other on this goddamn boat
we went to mexico
what a [ __ ] this place is
mexicans i get it now run jump swim
get the [ __ ] out of that place man
[Applause]
it stinks
and we're at cozumel which is the french
riviera this dust ball in the country
and what they do man is you're sitting
in your room
and they you have these little bitty tvs
and they play these subliminal messages
over and over to get you to go on these
shore excursions like you're just
sitting there all day long it's like do
you want to go snorkeling in mexico
wake up tomorrow go snorkeling in mexico
oh you should go circling in mexico
my brother and i are sitting there going
we'll do anything to get off this
[ __ ] boat what do we got to do
this was the commercial i swear to god
word for word i memorized it must have
played a thousand times it goes
are you ready to go snorkeling in mexico
you'll be picked up on a 50-foot
catamaran as you sail across blue waters
you'll dive amongst coral reefs and swim
with pretty tropical fish
that's not what happened
no
five mexican guys with an australian
accent
pick us up on a 10-foot
trash bar that's all i could call it it
looked like the p.o.w ship from
waterworld remember that [ __ ] thing
and i'm picturing this beautiful island
and everything we're 10 feet away from
the cruise ship they lower a drawbridge
just start [ __ ] kicking people off
we're out there swimming through diesel
fuel
the water looked like the bottom of a
dumpster after mardi gras
it was just there's no fish living in
this water you couldn't see a reef if it
was in front of your face
i saw like a half eaten box of adult
diapers and a bunch of chicklets
floating in the water
and then we went to jamaica oh dear what
a wonderful place that is
[Applause]
if you're a criminal
they got four-year-olds with glocks
tucked in their diapers man smoking
cigarettes [ __ ]
we had this couple man we had this old
couple that stayed next door to me and
my brother she they were so nice man
they must have been on a thousand
cruises and every time we would stop
somewhere they'd come over like julie
cruz director knock on the door and tell
us what we had to do so we're in jamaica
like
oh my god court
we're in jamaica you have got to go kiss
the dolphins
it's only 250 dollars
i'm thinking 250 dollars
this dolphin better have no teeth swim
up suck my dick when i get this pool
i live in california that shit's free
[ __ ]
my brother and i want somebody at the
casino we're like let's go get our dick
sucked by a dolphin
but i got to tell you about this man we
went on this we went on this excursion
thing man and you go we get in this bus
with about 25 people the driver has a
gun on his lap we go through three
goddamn war zones to get to this
aquarium
and then you come off this bus and you
go to this hallway and you go and you're
going to the water the water's waste
deep they hand you a life that's like
you're going on the goddamn titanic i
swear to god you got this huge life vest
on everybody wades into this pool of
dolphin [ __ ] that's all i can it's
disgusting one of the dolphins had a
cold sore [ __ ] you know it was
disgusting
and there's all these people standing
they just parade these poor mammals by
like their singapore sex slaves
everyone's just molesting them one by
one
and the guy next to me turns to me and
he goes whatever you do don't touch the
dolphin's penis
like the last thing i want's a picture
of my mantel of me jacking off a dolphin
you